ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS BATES
BELL MORTGAGES BRADFORD
CAMBIADO CHAIN DALLY DONT BUT
ALSO GALGIANI GLAZER GONZALEZ
GROOVE HERTZBERG HILL WEST SO-
TADO JACKSON JONES LEYVA
MCGUIRE MITCHELL MONNING MORE
LOCK MORALE NIELSEN PAN
PORTANTINO ROTH RUBIO SKINNER
STERN. NUMBER WHY CAO SKI
WIENER WILK. MEMBERS A QUORUM
IS PRESENT WITH THE MEMBERS IN
OUR BEST BE ON THE RAIL AND IN
THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE WE WILL
BE LEAD IN PRAYER THIS
AFTERNOON BY OUR CHOPPER SISTER
MICHELLE GORMAN AFTER WHICH
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING WHO WE
WILL BE GLAD. THE OF A TO THE
EDITOR. YEAH LET US CENTER
OURSELVES IN GOD'S PRESENCE
CORNELL TORTURE IS AN AMERICAN
ASTRONOMER AND THE FORMER
DIRECTOR OF THE SETI INSTITUTE.
WORKING ON THE SEARCH FOR
EXTRATERRESTRIAL INTELLIGENCE.
SHE SAID. ULTIMATELY WE
ACTUALLY ALL BELONG TO ONLY ONE
TRIBE TO EARTHLINGS. CREATE OF
PRESENCE ARE GODS WE WISH TO BE
WITH YOUR HELP WISER THAN WE
ARE. WE THANK YOU FOR THOSE
CREATIVE PEOPLE LIKE BILL
CHARTER WHO SEARCH THE UNIVERSE
FOR OTHER LIFE ONLY TO REMIND
US OF OUR NEEDS TO APPRECIATE
THE ASTONISHING. TENTH OF THE
MOVING BREED OF CREATURE. IN
OUR OWN PLANET. DURING SPIRITS
IT WITH US EARTHLINGS AS WE
COME TOGETHER IN OUR STRUGGLES
PULLING OUR WISDOM AND OUR
ENERGIES OF HOPE. CONVINCED IN
THE END ALL WILL SOMEHOW BE
WELL A MAN. THE CHANCE TO THE
FLAG. THIS IS. GEN SCHOOL YEAH
ALL. IN MEMBERS ARE MOVING ON
TO PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR.
SENATOR LEYVA. SENATE. SENATOR
LEYVA AT THE MAJORITY LEADER'S
THIS THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
IF I COULD HAVE JUST A MOMENT
TO BRING OUR VOLLEYBALL PLAYERS
IN THE. YEAH. SO I CAN ASK ALL
OF THEM OF THE MEMBERS TO
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEAT AS WE
BEGIN OUR SESSION TODAY.
SENATOR LABOR THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS PLEASE
JOIN ME IN WELCOMING TO THE
SENATE FLOOR TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN DOUBLE EIGHT OF TO
LPNS CALIFORNIA'S UNIVERSITY
SAMFORD IN A WOMEN'S VOLLEYBALL
TEAM THE C. S. U. S. B. WOMEN'S
FOOTBALL TEAM IS RANKED NUMBER
IN THE NATION LET'S AGAIN FOR
ONE. THANK I COULD HAVE. ONLY
TO THOSE MATCHES WERE TAKEN TO
FIVE SETS WHICH INCLUDES THEIR
DECEMBER FOURTEENTH TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN CHAMPIONSHIP
MATCH AGAINST THE PREVIOUS. BE
PERSON OF NUMBER. THIS IS THE
FIRST NATIONAL CHAMPIONSHIP FOR
THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY. OUT OF THE WOMEN'S
VOLLEYBALL TEAM IS THE FIRST
TEAM FROM CALIFORNIA TO COMPLY
CARE CLAIM IT IS INTO TITLE
SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE SO
THESE WOMEN ARE PRETTY AMAZING
THEY'RE ALSO THE THIRD TEAM AN
NC DOUBLE A HISTORY TO CAPTURE
THE- DURING THE FEET IT'S- THE-
SELECT. A VICE FOR. ON FERAL
HEAD COACH KIM TURN AS AN
ASSOCIATE HEAD COACH DANNY
SCOTT RIGHT NOW I'D LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE SOME OF THESE
AMAZING WOMEN WHEN I CALL YOUR
NAME PUT YOUR HAND UP. ALEXIS
CARDOZA. SASHA DOM. THEY SAY
THAT EVEN CLOSE TO BEING RIGHT
WAS IT IS THAT RIGHT OKAY I WAS
CLOSE OKAY THANK YOU KALEY
SCOTT. G. PAYS. MAHANE MAW.
THESE THIS HARD WORK AND
DEDICATION SHOWN BY THESE WOMEN
ATHLETES ALL WHAT THE BALANCE
BEINGBUSY SCHEDULES ACADEMIC
SCHEDULES AND BREAKING RECORDS
AND WINNING A CHAMPIONSHIP IS
TRULY A ME THING. BECAUSE IT'S
WITH. PLEASURE THAT I BRING
THESE WHAT YOUNG. CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE FLOOR PLEASE LET'S
GIVE THEM A ROUND OF APPLAUSE.
THE BIG SENATE CONGRADULATIONS
TO THE CSU SANDRA DINO
VOLLEYBALL TEAM.
CONGRATULATIONS TO THE CSU
SAMBAR NINO VOLLEYBALL TEAM ARE
VERY PROUD OF YOU THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US HERE TODAY. MOVING
ON. MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
WILL BE DEEMED READ MESSAGES
FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE
DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICED.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE FOLLOWING
BILLS WITH FLOOR AMENDMENTS
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. SENATOR
MITCHELL THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU I MET A PRESENT UNDER
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
THERE'S A LOT TO DESPERATE TO
WITHDRAW SENATE BILLS EIGHT OWN
NINE TWO EIGHT FOUR EIGHT FROM
THE B. FROM THE BUDGET FISCAL
REVIEW COMPETE. AN ORDER THE
BILLS TO THE READING. CENTER
GROVE I REQUEST A ROLL CALL
VOTE AND REPUBLICANS VOTE NO
PLEASE. THERE IS A REQUEST FOR
A ROLL CALL VOTE. REPUBLICANS
ARE ASKING FOR A NO VOTE.
MAJORITY LEADERS ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ARCHULETA. ATKINS. PLEASE
BELL. GORGEOUS. BRADFORD HI
COME A YELLOW BY CHANGING. THE
ALLEY NO DODD. THEY'RE ALSO HI
GALGIANI HI GLAZER HI GONZALEZ.
HI ROSE NO HERTZBERG WITHIN
HILL. HELLO ALL HUESO HI TADO
HI JACKSON HI JONES NO LEYVA.
HI THE C<c.cyan>. HI MITCHELL. HI</c>
MONNING. MORE LOCK NO MORALE NO
NIELSEN NO HAN HI PORTANTINO.
ROSS HI RUBIO HI SKINNER. STERN
HI I'M BURKE HI LIKE CAL SKI HI
WIENER HI WILK NO. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS A REMINDER
BUT YOU'RE THE LEADER IN ASKING
FOR AN I. O. ALLEN HI. LET US
AYE ATKINS. WELL HI BURGESS NO
CHIANG NO DODD. HI HERTZBERG HI
MONNING. HI PORTANTINO HI
SKINNER. THE MOTION PASSES BUYS
TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS TEN. MEMBERS
OF WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE.
MOVING ON TO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS. ITEMS NUMBER ONE
AND NUMBER TWO SENATOR WILK.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE IS
A CONFIRMATION OF COMEDY GIPSON
AS DIRECTOR OF THE DIVISION OF
A DAHLE INSTITUTIONS AT CDC ARE
MISS GIPSON HAS SPENT HER
ENTIRE THIRTY TWO YEAR CAREER
AT C. C. R. A NEW PERSONAL.
ARMIN ANONYMOUS FIVE A VOTE BY
THE RULES COMMITTEE ON. THE
FEBRUARY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
ABOUT. THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS APPOINTMENT. IN
NINE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. HI LET US I
ATKINS PLEASE HI BEL HI FORGES
HI BRADFORD HI HI CAMBIADO HI
CHANGE HI SALLY. I DODD HI
THERE ALSO HI GALGIANI. HI
GLAZER. HI GONZALEZ BY GROWS HI
HERTZBERG HI HILL HI WES SO. HI
TADO HI JACKSON. HI JONES ARE
BY LEYVA. HI MCGUIRE BY
MITCHELL. HI MONNING HI AMBER
MORE LOCK. HIGH MORALE. HI
NIELSEN. HI TEN HI PORTANTINO.
HI ROSS FIVE RUBIO. SKINNER
STERN. BY ON BURKE. HI HI WHY
CAN'T SKI HI WIENER HI WILK HI.
PLEASE CALL THE MEMBERS ATKINS
RUBIO HI SKINNER. THIRTY SEVEN
EYES NOSE ZERO THE APARTMENT IS
APPROVED. SENATOR WELCOME THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO IS A CONFIRMATION OF
OUR VERY OWN SENATOR MCGUIRE TO
THE PACIFIC STATE SUPREME
FISHING FISHERIES. HE WAS
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON FEBRUARY NINETEENTH ON A
THREE TWO VOTE. NO ACTUALLY THE
FIGHT IT WAS A UNANIMOUS VOTE.
I RESPECTFULLY RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR. SENATOR HERTZBERG THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I AM DEEPLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THIS-
APPOINTMENT SO HE IS SOMEONE
WHO IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO
THIS THE INVOLVED IN MANY OF
OUR POURTANT ISSUES AND I AM
NOT SO BIRDS THREE AS THE TIME
TO. THE APPROPRIATE ATTENTION
TO THE- POURTANT UP IS THE
COMMISSION THE PACIFIC STATES
MARINE FISHERIES IN HIS
DISTRICT. THE GOLDEN GATE
BRIDGE THE OREGON BORDER SAME
TIME WORK BUT ALL THESE ISSUES
I RAISE THAT FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION MEMBERS. A
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SENATOR ARCHULETA. MADAM
PRESIDENT I BELIEVE THIS
APPOINTMENT SOUNDS AWFULLY
FISHY TO ME- IN SENATOR SENATOR
BRIDGES BUT SENATOR- MORE
LOCKED THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- I STAND IN REBUTTAL
TO THE SENATOR FROM AS ANGELES.
I THINK THE SENATOR NO ME TO BE
APPOINTED TO A LEASE NOTED THAT
MORE COMMITTEES. HE HAS GOT SO
MUCH ENERGY SO SHOULD. I WE TO
PUT IN WHEREVER WE CAN SO I
RECOMMEND AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT. IS THERE ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SAYING NINE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
ARCHULETA. ATKINS BATES BELL.
FOR JESS. BRADFORD CABALLERO HI
CHANGE. DALLY NO. DAWN ROSS SO.
GALGIANI HI GLAZER. GONZALEZ HI
ROSE NO HERTZBERG. HILL WES SO
TADO. JACKSON HI JONES- NO
LEYVA. I BY MCGUIRE. MITCHELL.
MONNING. MORE LOCK HIGH MORALE.
NIELSEN PAN. PORTANTINO NO ROTH.
RUBIO SKINNER STERN- HI AMBERG.
WHY CAO SKI BY WIENER YEAH.
WILK HI. THE THIS LOOKS A BIT
IFFY BUT I'M ASKED TO CALL THE
ROLL AGAIN. ALLEN. HI ARCHULETA
HI ATKINS BATES HI BEL YEAH. HI
FORGES HI BRADFORD HE HI CHANGE
HI DAHLE. HI THERE ALSO. HI
GLAZER. HI HERTZBERG BY HILL
AYE HUESO. HI HI RICARDO. HI
MCGUIRE. MONNING HIGH MORALE HI
HI NIELSEN. HI PAN. I ROTH.
PORTANTINO NOTE HI ROSS HI
RUBIO. HI SKINNER I'M BURKE. HI
WIENER. HI JONES NO DIE. GROVE
NO TO AYE DALY NOTED I. I
THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED.
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO READ WE'RE RETURNING TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THIS IS
THE TIME TO ADDRESS THE ADJOURN
IN MEMORIES. SENATOR JEFF.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES TODAY I RISE DURING
APPROPRIATELY OF WOMEN'S
HISTORY MONTH TO ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF FRAUDULENT PALMER
WALKER. ALTER EXCUSE ME IS
KNOWN AS THE ORIGINAL ROSIE THE
RIVETER. SHE ARE PASSED AWAY ON
MARCH FOURTH IN HER HOME IN
MANHATTAN SHE WAS BORN JUNE
TWENTY FOURTH NINETEEN TWENTY
FOUR IN BROOKLYN SHE GREW UP
WITH THE OF ALL THE BETTER
SERVE. UPPER CLASS LIFE IT.
SWIM INTO IT. EIGHT PREPARE
APPROACH OR A BOARDING SCHOOL-
AND- IT SHOWS THOUGH DURING
WORLD WAR TWO TO COME FORWARD
TO STEP UP AND TO WORK IN THE
ASSEMBLY LINE ADD VOTE-
AIRCRAFT COMPANY THE JOB THAT
HAD PREVIOUSLY BEEN RESERVE
MAN. SHE RIGHT OR SHAR OF
FIGHTER PLANES AND- WHEN SHE
WAS WRITTEN ABOUT IN A
NEWSPAPER ARTICLE A SONG WAS
WRITTEN ABOUT ROSIE THE RIVETER
THE SONG CAPTURED IN HISTORICAL
MOMENT THAT HELP SO THE SEED TO
THE WIND WITHIN THE LAST HALF
OF TWENTIETH CENTURY B. SHE
SAYS WELL AS OTHER WOMEN WHEN
ON A TWO DAY TRIP. MANUFACTURED
SAID. THE BEEN BY MEN WHO OF
MANY FOR OFF FIGHTING IN THE
WAR. SHE ARE. WAS A SOMEONE WHO
TOOK HER RESPONSIBILITIES AS AN
AMERICAN AND AS A WOMAN VERY
SERIOUSLY. AND AFTER THE WAR
LATER IN HER LIFE SHE BECAME A
MAJOR PHILANTHROPIST AND ONE OF
PBS THIS PRINCIPLE BENEFACTORS.
MANY YEARS AGO I GUESS YEARS
AGO WHEN WE HONORED THE PASSAGE
OF THE FAIR PAY ACTED ROSY
RIVETER MUSEUM. IN REACH
CALIFORNIA. IN OTHERS OF THE
ORIGINAL ROSY GROUP THEY'RE
WEARING THEIR BANDANNAS AND
PUMPING THEIR FISTS- AS A
REMINDER THAT WOMEN HAVE. THE
NEW TO AND DESIRE TO REPEAT IT
THE TO THE ADVANCES AND TO THE
CHALLENGES ASSOCIATED WITH THIS
COUNTRY. ROSIE THE RIVER. ALSO
IN PALMER WALTER PASSED AWAY
HAVING BEEN THE FIRST TO LEAD
THE CHARGE THERE ARE MANY THAT
HAVE FOLLOWED AFTER HER AND
HOPEFULLY THERE WILL BE MANY
OTHERS WHO WILL LEAD THE PATH
TO WOMEN'S EQUALITY WITH THAT I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY. THERE WE
PERMIT. FOR BRIEF YOUR NAME
FORWARD AND I'M A MORRELL HER
ARE HER HERE ON THE SENATE
FLOOR. SENATOR BELL. MADAM
PRESIDENT- TODAY I RISE REQUEST
ON A JOURNEY IN MEMORY OF- THE
LATE SUSAN HAMMER SAN JOSE.
SUSAN WAS THE MAYOR OF SAN JOSE
OF THE NINETEEN- LATE NINETEEN
EIGHTIES AND NINETEEN NINETIES
THROUGHOUT THE NINETEEN
NINETIES HE SERVED PREVIOUSLY
TO AS A MEMBER OF THE SAN JOSE
CITY COUNCIL AND- ICE WAS SUED
FOR TWELVE YEARS- AS A- COUNCIL
MEMBER. HE WAS MORE THAN ROOM
WROTE. I WENT TO UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA BERKELEY AND WORK
WITH HER HUSBAND PHIL ON HER
FIRST POLITICAL CAMPAIGN WAS
FOR JOHN KENNEDY AND THEN HE
GOT A JOB ON THE FIRST PEACE
CORPS STAFF. SHOULD RETURN HOME
TO THE PROPOSAL ON TENNIS SAN
JOSE AND GOT INVOLVED IN
POLITICS- SHE WAS A SERVE
CHAMPION OF WOMEN'S RIGHTS.
HAVE NOT. HER VERY VERY WELL
CAN LIVE SHIP AND INCLUDE. PUSH
FOR DIVERSITY WITHIN CITY BORE
AND COME. AND A DEEP COMMITMENT
TO UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES SOUR
HER ACCOMPLISHMENTS INCLUDED-
CREATING A GREEN LINE AROUND
SAN JOSE TO TROLL SPUR.
EXPANDING OUR IN CELEBRATING
CULTURE SHE PASSED A LIVING
WAGE ORDINANCE WELL WELL THEM
WHILE SHE WAS MAYOR IN THE
NINETEEN IS. AT ARE CREATED A
HOUSING PROGRAM. FOR LOW INCOME
HOUSING ALSO A GANG TASK FORCE
AND OPENED- USE CENTERS IN SAN
JOSE. A SUSAN HAD A GOOD SENSE
OF HUMOR AND- AS A COUNCIL
MEMBER WORKING WITH HER I FOUND
HER TO BE ONE OF THE MOST
COLLEGIAL- UNDERSTANDING AND-
COLLABORATIVE MAYOR THAT I EVER
SER WITH AN AYE SIR WOULD FOR
MAYORS. DURING HER TENURE. FOR
OF THE CITY'S MOST COMPLETE.
SIGNIFICANT PUBLIC BUILDINGS
WERE COMMISSION- WE HAVE THE-
SAN JOSE REPERTORY THEATRE
WHICH IS NOW THE SUSAN A BILL
HAMMER THEATER. WE COMPLETED
THE MEXICAN HERITAGE PLAZA A
MAJOR CULTURAL CENTER IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA FOR MAKERS
MEXICAN HERITAGE- THE SAP
CENTER THAT'S OUR SHARK TANK.
AND PROBABLY MOST
SIGNIFICANTLY- THE JOY JOB. A
LIBRARY DAY DEVELOPED A JOINT
LIBRARY WITH SAN JOSE STATE
UNIVERSITY AND THE CITY OF SAN
JOSE WHICH IS ONE OF THE
LARGEST LIBRARIES IN CALIFORNIA
NOW THE JOINT LIBRARY BETWEEN
SOME OF THE STATE. AND SAN JOSE
CITY SERVICES LEADERSHIP LAID A
STRONG ECONOMIC FOUNDATION ALSO
FOR THE TECH INDUSTRY- OF
WELCOMING COMPANY LIKE ADOBE GO
TO TOWN WAS A- AND SHE SERVED
AFTER SHE- LEFT THE MAYORSHIP
OF SAN JOSE TO THE BOARD OF
EDUCATION APPOINTED BY GOVERNOR
GRAY DAVIS. SHE WAS A LEADER
WAS A STRONG FOR SMALL AND
COMPASSIONATE PERSON. MARK
LIVES TO LIVE SIR TO OUR- ENTER
LET SEE WILL BE C. AND SALAS
FOR JENNA. SHE PASSED AWAY AT
HER HOME IN COMPANY OVER FAMILY
IS SURVIVED BY HER HUSBAND PHIL.
CHILDREN FILL HALLIE AND MATH
AND SIX GRANDCHILDREN. AND WE
LIKE TO TURN THE SENATE IN HER
MEMORY THE GREAT MAYOR SAN JOSE
SUSAN HAMMER. CAN'T WOMAN
ELECTED MAYOR IN SAN JOSE AND-
I CABS. BRING THE MATTER
HAMMERS NAME TO THE DEATH SO
SHE CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED IN THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING HER NAME FORWARD. IF
THERE IS NO BUSINESS CENTER
ATKINS THE DESK IS CLEAR. THANK
YOU MADAM FOR US THURSDAY MARCH
TWELFTH WE WILL RECONVENE AT
NINE AM. ANNOUNCEMENT THE
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS WILL MEET IN
THE MADDIE LOUNGE AT THE END OF
SESSION AND THE REPUBLICANS
WILL MEET IN ROOM THREE OH
FIVE. THE SENATE WILL RECESS
UNTIL THREE WHICH TIME THE
TOURNAMENT MOTION WILL BE MADE
WE WILL RECONVENE THURSDAY NINE
AM. WE ARE CONCLUDE.